Aloha it is me Bremen Brock and today I
will be answering 30 questions in three
minutes with BuzzFeed but before I do
make sure you guys check out my new
collaboration with wet-and-wild called
jungle rock at the nearest Walgreens
Walmart Target and if you're a mother
Canada super greens or know enough super
greens super drugs sorry is not from
here I'm not even from America at all
let's get started I have to be my
mascara because I'm on mascara expert
Wi-Fi my phone and a boat oh my man cuz
you know I first stuck in Ireland like
you know we have to repopulate somewhere
over the rainbow by Bharata age Forrest
Gump by Forrest Gump I like to watch to
talk on YouTube cute sexy I'm beautiful
my own jungle rock collection
specifically using the shade Rihanna not
that she needs a makeover or anything I
was just like to hang out with her Tana
just cuz I think we're both a hot mess
James Charles cuz I think I would just
like burn him down to bridges and um
Peter pie so that's good that came up in
my head right now I don't have a reason
why I'm hotboxing oh sorry um iced
coffee a venti iced vanilla latte would
soymilk an extra shot of espresso
cinnamon powder on top with nitro lid
cuz we saved the Turtles well when she
was born and wasn't talking yet now she
talks too much
well I have another gmail account so I
would say Berman Roth oh comedy you know
me girl around 6 hours and 34 minutes
Oh cotton candy from
just kidding I'm lactose but if I was in
lactose I really like the cotton candy
from baskin-robbins
Otto because you can find my jungle rock
collection with Guatemala oh it's like
the sparkling emoji is like three like
little sparkles
I love Nicki Minaj one where she's like
did I lie did I lie did i dark I feel
like people who have like mouths have
issues like daddy issues oh it's my new
car I love this her name is sushi
Webster inspired by stormy Webster
because I'm Kylie Jenner nakita last
night because she was like come over I
have a joint that's an astrology girl
what our astrology thoughts on me is the
question cuz I'm a Leo so you know what
I mean when I see farms and I honestly
think I was like a farm worker and I
love farms i resonate with farms I've
never like been in farms like that or
worked in farms but I just feel like I'd
be really good at picking rice blow-by
Beyonce I think miss very my lashes at
my ass I feel and my lips and everything
about me
it's in there good stank breath like
your mouth is right next to your nose
but I'm so sorry if you have halitosis
are going judge
[Music]